j'aurai une réunion spéciale et à
monsieur olivier marleix estime son
président monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur parmi les très nombreuses
auditions menées par la commission d'
enquête présidée par georges fenech sur
les attentats de 2015 un témoignage nous
a particulièrement troublé c'est celui
de l'un des policiers de la bac arrivé
au bataclan quelques minutes seulement
après le début de la tuerie
voyant que son armement et celui de ses
collègues ne suffirait pas à riposter il
a sollicité l'état major de la
préfecture de police pour que les huit
militaires de l'opération sentinelles
présent à ses côtés équipés de fusil
famas puisse engager le feu il nous a
indiqué avoir eu pour toute réponse
négatif vous n'engagerait pas les
militaires on n'est pas en zone de
guerre
un des terroristes tiraient pourtant à
l'extérieur vers l'espace public passage
amelot et je vous le rappelle les
premiers hommes de la berri ne sont
arrivés sur place qu environ 20 minutes
plus tard cette situation soulève
évidemment monsieur le ministre
deux interrogations très précises
auxquelles nous aimerions avoir des
réponses tout aussi précise première
question pourquoi au bataclan votre
ministère sollicitée at il refusé
l'intervention de ses soldats présents
sur place à cet effet deuxième question
pour l'avenir la loi antiterroriste de
2016 établi un nouveau régime de
légitime défense qui conforterait dans
une situation similaire au bataclan une
éventuelle intervention des militaires
de sentinelle encore faudrait-il que
l'autorité civile que vous êtes et que
vous êtes seul ministre de la défense a
rappelé devant la commission denquête
leur donne l'ordre d'intervenir
quelles dispositions opérationnelles
avez-vous donc prises pour mieux
intégrer les dix mille militaires de
sentinelle et éviter à l'avenir un tel
dysfonctionnement
merci monsieur marleix que la parole est
à monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député marc l'ex comme vous
le savez la commission
dans quel parlementaire qui a rendu son
rapport a été reçue ce matin au
ministère de l'intérieur ce qui pouvait
participer à cette rencontre ont été
témoins d'une discussion apaisé et ont
pu constater ce que j'ai eu l'occasion
de répéter tout au long des travaux de
cette commission c'est à dire l'entière
disponibilité du ministère de
l'intérieur pour faire en sorte que nous
puissions constamment et hausser nos
dispositifs de sécurité
le premier point sur lequel je voudrais
insister c'est que le rapport de
monsieur pietrasanta et extrêmement
clair sur les conditions d'intervention
des forces de sécurité intérieure au
bataclan établi une chronologie
extrêmement précises de cette
intervention et conclu par le fait que
cette intervention s'est passé compte
tenu des conditions de l'attak dans les
meilleures conditions qu'il était
possible
et de ce point de vue là les conclusions
du rapport sont extrêmement claires et
je pense que pour la sérénité des débats
pour la vérité que l'on doit aux
victimes j'ai reçu les deux associations
de victimes hier
il est très important que l'on ne fasse
pas dire à ce rapport le contraire de ce
qu'il contient et j'invite tous ceux qui
peuvent le lire puisqu'il est en ligne
tous les parlementaires qui peuvent le
lire à ce
référer aux conclusions du rapporteur
elles sont extrêmement claires est
légèrement différent de l'interprétation
que vous venez d'en faire le deuxième
point sur lequel je voudrais insister
c'est sur le fait que pour répondre à
l'interrogation que vous avez exprimées
et dans un contexte où il peut y avoir
des tueries de masse
nous avons complètement refonder les
conditions d'intervention des forces
spécialisées et nous avons ré articuler
les conditions d'intervention des
primo-arrivants des primes aux
intervenants et des forces spécialisées
en réarmant notamment les bacs et les
psig et nous l'avons fait de façon
extrêmement rapide de manière à ce que
le puissions avoir les meilleures
conditions à même pas